well joining us next from east london is
patrick english for uh yugo thank you
very much very much for being on the
program
and patrick it's now over to the
conservative party members is that
you've been doing some polling recently
taking the temperature of where their
heads are at who do you think would win
the race between rishi cena and liz
trust now we know the final two
well certainly right now our polling is
suggesting that as it stands this trust
has about a 20 point leave a lead over
rishi sunap heading into any sort of
contest so she said that certainly has a
lot to do his position improved somewhat
in between the problem that we managed
to publish yesterday and the polling
from last week but certainly right now
we would say that liz trust is the front
runner among conservative party members
how volatile a group
are they because it does feel as if
there's been lots of fluctuations uh
even in the last week or so
about who their preferred handle
oh 100 absolutely so in the most recent
polling this trust appears to have the
upper hand particularly in those
head-to-heads the time before that penny
morden was a clear favor amongst certain
party members and then just a week
before that it was ben wallace flashback
to january rishi sunac was the one who
was way ahead with the membership and
this trust was in his weight so
certainly this is a very volatile
membership certainly i would say it's
all to play for but heading into the
contest heading into the summer is this
trust who does have that have that upper
hand according to our figures
it always looked like rishi sunak was
going to make it onto the final ballot
do you think he's got an easier or a
more difficult opponent facing liz trust
than he would have if penny morden got
through
well certainly according to our polling
liz trust is a more difficult candidate
for richie soon act to face if we look
at the head-to-heads we published
yesterday liz trust as i say had a
20-point lead over mushy sunak if we
look at penny morgan that league was cut
down to 15 and richie sunak improved his
position over penny morden considerably
in between those two polls so i think if
looking ahead you should know will
probably would rather have placed penny
more than the runoff liz trust probably
is a stronger candidate films have to
face in that regard yes
and i'm not sure if this is something
that you've looked into but are there
any specific issues that you think we
should sunek would have to deal with if
he is to have a shot at winning over the
conservative party membership are they
for example
a group of people who tend to be worried
about you know taxation or the economy
or spending what is it
absolutely so we've been asking
conservative members what it is that
they really want from their next leader
and their next prime minister and the
next person to take on kirsh dharma at
the next general election and what
they've been telling us is that they
want to return to sort of conventional
conservatism so that's things like
cutting tax and spending and i think at
the moment perhaps one thing that's
holding rishi soon at back is his let's
say lukewarm commitment to cutting taxes
certainly the moment he's saying he
wants to get control of inflation first
and then think about cutting taxes
whereas all of the other candidates were
offering tax cutting platforms so i
think certainly that's an area that
might be hurting with membership right
now and you might need to look at that
and see what he can do in terms of
making a different kind of offer but yes
they are looking at tax and spending
they're also looking at things like
returning to honesty and integrity and
having a strong personality so there are
other things that the candidates could
choose to campaign on but taxing and
spending and in general kind of return
to that conventional conservatism is a
popular theme that we're getting from
the conservative members that we're
polling right now
and how different an electorate are they
from the public at large because it is
interesting isn't it that a relatively
small group of people effectively get to
choose the next prime minister
yes it is indeed they are as would not
be surprising at all quite a different
tribe to the general public at large the
general public is very split on whether
there should be tax cuts versus uh more
spending on public services or property
funding i guess public services whereas
the conservative party members are much
more in favor of tax costs so it is a
very uh let's say a niche electorate to
be appealing to and i think the
candidates will have to think about that
as the campaign starts to draw to a
close and perhaps members will start
thinking about that as well it's all
very well and good appealing directly to
the membership but if those pictures are
going directly against the grain of
public opinion in the general public and
the voting public at large that might
run them into some trouble looking ahead
to the general election so i think what
we might expect to see is perhaps some
heads turn toward the general public and
some of the debates turn toward maybe
sort of wider economic issues and cost
of living
will go down so so very well and the
public are desperate to hear about in
the minutes as the campaign goes on
okay interesting south patrick and just
in english there or
yoga